[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today we will be
talking about the utter craziness that
just happened in the seven deadly sins
story brace yourselves because we just
got major answers to some of the biggest
lingering questions from the last few
chapters of the manga and a new arc has
seemingly been confirmed although I
certainly did not expect this new arc to
go in the direction that it has with
that said I now believe that not only
one more but potentially several more
arcs could be on the way and the
trolling of the seven deadly sins fans
by the mangaka NACA bouzouki continues
in epic fashion man there is just so
much to talk about and I can't wait to
get into it if you enjoyed the some
daily sense content on this channel you
can leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime lore don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
and of course this video will contain
manga spoilers we are discussing the
latest events in the manga so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned chapter 311 of the manga starts
off with everyone breathing a huge sigh
of relief as they realize that Elizabeth
did not die in the cliff collapse from
the end of the last chapter
Merlyn managed to teleport Elizabeth
just in time although Elizabeth was
injured in the process this is what I
said I thought would happen in my
previous seven Billy cents video I just
couldn't see Elizabeth actually dying so
I thought that she would come out of the
rubble injured but alive
however in the previous video I also
predicted that this next arc would
involve the supreme deity but as we
found out later in this chapter and that
is not the case at least not yet but
more on that later we then see that
Elizabeth's curse has manifested once
again even though meliodas had seemingly
destroyed it back in Chapter 306 meliora
then uses an incredible power a power
that is seemingly on the same level as
the power of the demon king to destroy
the curse once again but even after that
the curse just regenerates once more
when s Kannur asks why only Elizabeth's
curse regenerating meliora says that his
curse had been placed upon him by the
supreme deity but Elizabeth's was placed
upon her by the demon
King and as bond points out this
regeneration of the curse seems to
indicate that the demon king hasn't yet
kicked the bucket the demon king still
hasn't been defeated and speaking of
bond the long-awaited
and highly requested new anime approach
shirts are finally here introducing bond
love the pain created by pro manga
artist KU zhu money and also s Kannur
all hail the one s Kannur in his the one
form also created by Cuusoo mary if you
want to get these new shirts and support
the channel at the same time check out
any map or comm link in the description
now I don't know about you but I was a
bit confused about who placed the curse
on whom 3,000 years ago and I guess I
always thought that the demon king
cursed his own son and the supreme deity
cursed her own daughter however it now
appears that the demon king cursed
Elizabeth and the supreme deity cursed
Mele ODIs the different translations
were a bit murky on that in the past but
it now seems clear that this is the case
but even if we accept this fact it still
doesn't make complete sense because if
Elizabeth's curse is regenerating
because the demon king has not yet been
fully defeated then shouldn't the same
apply to melioidosis curse after all the
supreme deity hasn't been defeated
either we haven't seen her even fight
anyone yet
so why did meliodas succeed in
destroying her curse but not in
destroying Elizabeth's curse at this
point Gotha points out that that part of
the demon king that still hasn't been
defeated should not have been able to
find a new vessel because the animals
and humans around the place where they
battled would not be able to contain the
demon King's immense power their bodies
would simply disintegrate and that is
when we finally get the full story of
what exactly happened to zelgius after
the fight against the demon king it
turns out that after he was absolutely
wrecked by Maya with sunshine
the original demon did not die instead
he was split back into his two parts
Chandler and Cusack and the two of them
though visibly injured were at that
point still alive Chandler is confused
when he sees the 10 commandments
floating around outside because he
thought that they had been absorbed
by meliodas then Cusack sees zelgius is
severely injured unconscious body and he
hurries over to him
Chandler tells Kasich to forget the
quote worthless failure that is eldred's
and to help him retrieve the commandment
so that they can be offered to Mellie
Otis kusa doesn't react very well to
what Chandler said and he proceeds to
cut Chandler clean in half with his
sword as Chandler dies Cusack tells him
that it's nothing personal but Chandler
was going to get in the way of ku sucks
duty which is to ensure that his pupils
eldress becomes the next demon king
rather than Mellie Otis or anyone else
this turn of events is surprising
because Chandler was considered to be
stronger than Cusack but I guess under
the circumstances Cusack was able to
take out Chandler because he took him by
surprise and Chandler was also severely
injured so he was far from his full
potential we then realized that as the
demon king was being defeated by the
sins just a few chapters ago Cusack
snuck in there took Zell drous took the
ten commandments and escaped without
being noticed who suck proceeds to
explain why he is so loyal to Zell drous
he loves Zell drous as his own son and
he is willing to do anything for him
Cusack says that although these are
probably just the emotions that the
demon king planted inside him that is
still how he feels and he will do
whatever it takes to help zelgius
achieve his dreams Cusack proceeds to
place the 10 commandments inside the
body of Zell dress and presumably after
the required amount of time has passed
and not as instantly as it appears in
the chapter Zell dress emerges from the
cocoon
it seems that Cusack did not know what
zelgius meliodas and the others learned
just a few chapters earlier absorbing
all of the commandments doesn't make you
more powerful than the demon king it
merely makes the one who absorbs the
commandments a new vessel that the demon
king can take control of as the new
demon king zelgius emerges he
immediately destroys cusack simply
because he considers cusack to be
nauseating now in a new adult form just
like meliodas had been when he was
possessed by the demon king the new
demon king zelgius is born it is now
clear that instead of being defeated the
demon king has been resurrected yet
again
and now inside a brand-new vessel and
the next chapter chapter 312 is called
the war begins yes you heard that right
after all those epilogues and happy
ending chapters the next chapter is
going to be called the war begins Wow
this is such a troll I can't even anyway
to me this definitely seems like the
setup for a brand new demon king zelgius
Ark and even more arcs could be coming
in the future if the supreme deity ever
decides to stop chilling in the
celestial realm and that's without
taking into consideration the potential
for entirely new kingdoms and villains
potentially being introduced in the
future at this point I'm honestly
starting to think that na kvass Tsuzuki
may have changed his mind about ending
the series after all in recent years the
seven deadly sins has become an
extremely profitable and popular series
both in Japan and in the West and this
might have something to do with what is
now happening in the manga because to me
this feels like a total restart rather
than an ending and if naka bouzouki
really has changed his mind and he wants
to keep this story going there are
infinite possibilities to explore from
the supreme deity to the different
realms that we already know about like
the demon realm at the celestial realm
to potentially completely different
kingdoms realms and races or fantastical
creatures that may be introduced in the
future and so on the world of the seven
deadly sins really is an incredible rich
world and I want to know more about it
there's just so much potential in terms
of the whole demon King's eldress twist
I'm extremely excited to see where this
goes the demon king is not a fool and he
will not make the same mistake he made
while fighting the sins the demon king
is now aware that he can be defeated by
meli otis under certain circumstances so
instead of facing off against the sins
directly he may take a different more
crafty approach this time around he will
of course be dealing with resistance
from zelgius on the inside because
they'll just never wanted to be
controlled by his father in fact he
wanted to become the next demon king so
that he could rule much differently than
his father has been ruling for all these
years I expected gelda who is now free
and out looking for zelgius will play a
major role in this new arc zelgius will
need a massive amount of willpower in
order to resist the demon king and
seeing gelda alive once again may be the
exact kick in the
hands ljus we'll need to fight back from
the inside but the big question is what
will the demon king do now will he just
use the body of zelgius to attack the
sins and meliodas directly or has he
learned his lesson after losing to the
sins back while he was still possessing
the body of Mele otis will the demon
king resort to more sly and crafty means
to get one over on the sins this time
around will he hide and go for a
surprise attack will he attempt to open
the door to the demon realm and bring in
powerful demonic allies like the Endora
to help him fight against the sins or
will he simply wait it out because he
knows that meliodas has to leave the
mortal plane soon the natural disasters
have already started several chapters
ago so it doesn't seem like the demon
king would have to wait for very long
for meliodas to leave also now that it's
a new day I wonder if we'll actually get
to see my L in the one mode how insanely
epic would it be to see miles the one
versus demon king Sal drous I would have
been really disappointed if the story
ended without us even seeing my L using
the power of the one so here's hoping
that we'll get the privilege of
witnessing that at some point in the
future what do you guys think is this
new art going to be short and then it's
really going to end or did naka bouzouki
actually change his mind about ending
the series and this is just the
beginning of a whole new bunch of arcs
please let me know down in the comments
I need to know what everyone else is
thinking on this subject because I am
super confused but also intrigued if you
enjoy the seven deadly sins content on
this channel you can leave a like to let
me know and if you're new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell also don't forget
to check out our brand new bond love the
pain and esken or all hailed the one
shirts on anime out Broadcom a huge
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for supporting our work and when
I especially thank our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
keelon and chubs is the man and another
huge thank you to our the one to your
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ace Matty Mac
James a Lola Madame Ingrid ah and a
and at the very pinnacle of
interdimensional greatness the tier
reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to baby Rey the first-ever
disciple of Lord to ego himself if you
guys feel that our content provides
value for you and you want to support
more be sure to check out our patreon
link in the description even donating a
single dollar will give you access to
our anime out for patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate it and
until next time see our space cowboys
[Music]